Obama to the rescue that's the focus of
tonight's angle before President Trump
could even clarify a statements in
Helsinki
President Obama pounced speaking in
Johannesburg he hit the sitting
president populism and attempted to
breathe life into his own sad legacy
look around strongman politics are
ascendant suddenly whereby elections and
some pretense of democracy are
maintained the form of it but those in
power seek to undermine every
institution or norm that gives democracy
meaning ok well the people and their
will give democracy its meaning but
don't you love how Obama attempts to
write Putin Trump off as some Putin like
dictator Ln for good measure he tries to
lend credence to the line that Trump of
course is siding with the old KGB and
Putin over all of our intelligence
agents and services appoint the
president clarified and batted down
today as we just played in the previous
segment and let's not pretend that
America by the way hasn't had a history
of making convenient alliances with
unsavory strongmen we do so when
necessary to achieve greater objectives
for our country I'm thinking for
instance Mubarak and Saddam was saying
just to mention a few
and remember Obama himself abruptly cut
short a big meeting with our key
Democratic ally India to attend a
memorial service for King Abdullah of
Saudi Arabia a bit of a strongman don't
you think maybe some strong men are
better than others when Obama's involved
as a strong man they're fine the former
president also makes the mistake of
assuming that Trump and the millions of
people who turned out to vote for him
just came out of the ether it's dropped
from the sky well Trump was elected in
part because many Americans were fed up
with the weak man leadership of Barack
Obama the president who drew red lines
and disappearing ink
voters in Ohio Wisconsin Pennsylvania
and beyond had had it with globalism had
it with open borders and had it with
trade deals that gutted our
manufacturing and gave an upper hand to
China Trump voters were all so tired of
endless wars and they still are that's
called common sense conservative
populism but of course many in the
bipartisan establishment that Trump ran
against will never admit the failures of
globalization and instead like Obama
they choose to denigrate it skeptics in
the West you've got far-right parties
that oftentimes are based not just on
platforms of protectionism and closed
borders but also on barely hidden racial
nationalism
when in doubt play the race card well
this is just pure identity politics
that's what Obama is really good at and
on the global stage no less all to help
rescue Democrats in the midterms and by
the way couldn't could that be
interpreted as criticizing America on
the on the global stage in a foreign
country I think so
whipping up racial divisions is a
typical Democrat tactic and one we've
already seen deployed by for instance
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes the new bright
light of the Democrat Party Cory Booker
Kamala Harris Maxine Waters the list
goes on and on Obama there in
Johannesburg just makes it all sound
slightly more erudite with all those
pregnant pauses then of course he
couldn't resist launching the
internationalist tired old refrain
against populism with a few lines that
could have been written by george w bush
himself the fact that countries which
rely on rabid nationalism and xenophobia
and doctrines of tribal racial or
religious superiority as their main
organizing principle the thing that that
holds people together eventually those
countries find themselves consumed by
civil war or external war hope he's not
talking about our country well I think
think of Japan for instance which has a
strong
Streak prizes their culture and has a
very strict immigration policies are
they on the verge of Civil War I don't
think not I don't think so look Obama
star turned today was designed to seize
on the opening that the globalist feel
they have after Helsinki but as usual
they overreach and they have this really
convenient case of amnesia regarding
their own role in the rotten state of
affairs with Russia these are the facts
though Obama did not reset our
relationship with Russia even though he
bragged about it all the way through
2012 and Obama consistently
underestimated the challenge posed by
Putin's regime and this is the
assessment from the Brookings
Institution no fans of Trump writing at
the end of Obama's two terms Putin had
elevated Russia to a credible
revisionist power on the international
stage Russia annexed Crimea and occupied
much of eastern Ukraine by successfully
propping up the degenerate Assad regime
the Kremlin gained veto on any possible
political solution to Syria and got a
meaningful foothold in the broader
region feeling both anti-americanism and
illiberal ISM and most damning of all it
managed to meddle almost unopposed in
u.s. politics all on Obama's watch I
just read that in the makeup room
earlier the bottom line is this the two
biggest nuclear powers in the world
should have an open and frank line of
communication that's better for
America's security and guess what it's
better for global peace it's what
liberals used to be for more talk less
war Trump has a realistic and a
pragmatic view of the post Cold War era
the most serious threat to America
militarily and economically is not
Russia by the way with an economy
basically the size of Italy's in fact
the biggest threat to America is China
Trump is the first president to make
this plain and act accordingly with
tough talk and tougher actions including
tariffs that the globe
are all against and the globalists are
obsessed with Russia of course they say
precious little about China's incursions
China's cheating and China's threats why
because they make gobs of money on a
rising China
remember back in 2014 when the Chinese
military hacked into the federal
government's Office of Personnel
Management
China has home addresses Social Security
numbers in family information on 22
million current and former government
employees including mine
this was Barack Obama with president G
after the news broke I'm very friendly
did Obama confront G on the world stage
then about that hack huge intrusion no
he did not
and did the media make a big deal of
that no they did not
did pundits on MSNBC and CNN claimed
that Obama was in G's back pocket for
not calling him out no they did not but
back to Russia Trump said yesterday that
both sides deserve blame for the state
of the relationship now I might not have
said that while standing next to Putin
but in a 2016 BBC peace quoting Paul
Pilar a former CIA officer and foreign
policy expert he said the relationship
went wrong when the West did not treat
Russia as a nation that had shaken off
Soviet Communism it should have been
welcomed as such into the new community
of nations but instead it was regarded
as a successor state to the USSR
inheriting its status as the principal
focus of Western distrust he can debate
whether that was the right thing to do
but we opted to expand NATO he said and
failed in our attempts to turn Russia
into an ally albeit a cagey one now that
got Russia's back up and it boosted
Putin's popularity in his homeland the
truth is that lots of people have said
what Trump said yesterday that we should
have a better relationship with Russia
where we can guess who said it clinton
george w bush and yes barack obama
America wants a strong peaceful and
prosperous Russia that's why I have
called for a reset in relations between
the United States and Russia this must
be more than a fresh start between the
Kremlin and the White House it must be
sustained effort among the American and
Russian people to identify mutual
interests and expand dialogue and
cooperation that can pave the way to
progress sounds pretty good
so why is that thought now suddenly so
subversive oh because we have a
Republican president in the White House
and by the way a Republican president
who's backing up the conciliatory talk
building bridges with tough sanctions as
well hmm
well the Democrats have the midterms
ahead of them they're coming and Barack
Obama and the Democrats clearly fear
that Trump might succeed where they
failed and that's the angle